cameras crooked working with a new
tripod I'm sorry guys
hey Lisa welcome back thanks guys this
is Lisa Lisa's a friendly human being
with a soul for kindness
that was beautiful well we had a really
great conversation before this we did
have a great conversation I believe in
great conversations I do too speaking of
great conversations did you know that
there were like at least five actors who
died making movies yeah and we want to
make movies we want to be in movies we
could be on this list one day we get
from all-time movies I know Brandon Lee
died on the crow here we go fever what
Tom Cruise being strapped to a plane
that kind of recklessness can kill you
despite all the safety precautions thing
is movie stars
they're human they look at terminally
youthful and have what seems to be the
easiest job in the world
but they suffer the same emotional
problems and health issues that anyone
can endure and other times accidents can
happen light can be trying don't you
think so here are five actors who died
while making a movie and how the
filmmakers poked with their premature
departures so now number five now in
Monroe yeah I saw them in 1962
something's got to give was going to be
Marilyn Monroe's big comeback she hadn't
made a movie in a while
and had been suffering severe illness
and depression for a year sadly her
illness never went away and the film was
repeatedly delayed by Monroe's sick days
they got to the point where the director
didn't know whether or not he'd wake up
to a phone call from Marilyn saying
sorry I can't come on set today me she
tried to make up for it by doing a nude
publicity shoot on the set but things
got away from the studio fired her then
her Oh stars refused to do it without
her so the school rehired her and
Napoleon
you can hear that surely afterwards
though she died of a painkiller overdose
it was probably as suicide
she was just 36 really the film was
never finished the studio decided to cut
their losses and completely remake it as
move over dolly with Doris Day number
four
Tyrone Power Tyrone T was sort of like
the Mark of Zorro have been here once
again return which got a weird kind of
sequel in the maskers aura anyway Tyrone
was a dependent sword fighting with a
smile and made a career out of it
ironically though it was a sword fight
that killed him but think what filming
to do all on the set of his last film
Solomon and Sheba he had a heart attack
forty-four the studio replaced Tyrone
with his friend Gil Brynner who turned
down the lead role in Spartacus with
Stanley Kubrick to reshoot his mates
critical epic the film was poorly
received and is largely forgotten today
and thus Warnock is proud of the read
well yeah legend great actor and even
greater alcoholic Oliver Reed struggled
but he drink while making gladiator that
is until the film was on a break in
Malta read-aloud himself
one last binge in a drinking contest
against some British sailors apparently
he drank eight pints of lager twelve
double runs and half a bottle of whiskey
before having a fatal heart attack each
one he paid for the movie scoffs chose
to finish read scenes by creating a CG
mask of his face and pasting it onto a
body double and clever the editing
unused footage into a death scene that
wasn't even in the script it cost an
extra three point two million dollars to
complete Oliver's role number two John
Candy wagons East is a strange and
pretty [ __ ] comedy wasting the talents
of a really good cast so it's an even
greater shame that it was the late great
John Candy's final film
no candies final act was reportedly
making dinner for his assistants it was
the second of the way before going to
bed he died in his sleep from a heart
attack it may have been triggered by
Candy's insistence on performing a fist
fight himself instead of using a stunt
double he was only 43 to complete the
film they used a body double a voice
impressionist and some digital trickery
to reuse footage they shot of Kandi's
performance it's pretty obvious and all
the special effects in the world can't
replace the comedy skill that can be
brought to his films
rest in peace Uncle Buck number one does
what I said yeah sadly Lee makes it to
the top of the list because he was
actually killed by the movies rather
than because of some health condition or
self-inflicted injury killed Brandon Lee
was shot on the set of the crow who
accidentally left a dagger of lightning
as a gun then loaded it with blanks
before filming the key scene where these
character is shot and killed ironically
the blanks were saved and the bullet
wouldn't have hurt stuck in the barrel
but when you combine them it's fatal
after six hours of surgery Lee died from
the gunshot wound
he was just 28 Wow Lee only had three
days of shooting left on the film but
they were all key flashback scenes so
they rewrote the script used his stunt
double to film new scenes and digitally
superimposed Lee's face onto him muscle
memory and footage of be from other
scenes with new CD background Lee's
interesting footage only adds up to 30
seconds the budget went up by eight
million dollars Wow it works pretty
seamlessly and I'd say the crow is
definitely worth watching sadly these
aren't the only people to have died on a
movie set to learn more about the behind
the scenes tragedies of moviemaking
click right there to see the 5 deadliest
movie stunts thanks watching guys and
see you next time see you next time I'll
sign movies Wow
you know the insurance policies on
actors are very serious two things I got
brought up in my mind recently were when
Jackie Chan started doing movies in the
US with rush hour he was doing a stunt
that didn't have him attach the wires
and then they got upset so the studio's
got upset so do they have to you know
you have to have a stunt double you have
to do this and Jared Leto on his
personal life he's not even like
according his contract he shouldn't be
rock climbing he's doing this thing
where he's rebelling and posting on
Instagram that he's rebelling by like is
actually rock climbing I've heard of
actors not being cast to because of
health concerns
yeah there's actors who who could have
had like big careers but they had like a
scare moment where like they could like
they had a heart attack with a stroke
they wouldn't get cast for bigger
projects after that this is sad it's sad
it's cool do your own stunts but you
gotta be realistic
true although Tom Curtis doesn't believe
in the word realism was that I know now
he does some crazy stuff I don't know
what you want a stunt double no no at
least I don't want the people to know
that yeah well of course not but
sometimes no don't believe in it not
necessary I do all my own stunts people
I could do it all I'm like yeah Marilyn
Manson man so my god
Marilyn Monroe I did see that movie my
life with Marilyn for my week of
Maryland yes I do research after
watching the movie and like apparently
she was this woman who like really
suffered a lot with depression
she was someone though who really wanted
to become a serious actress yeah she
wanted to stop being known as just a sex
imagine this is not just based off this
movie I was even reading a book called
on method acting and they talked about
how she was a this case that came into
this the class one day and she would
study for hours and hours and hours to
really show that she had real talent
that she wasn't just that and
unfortunately that a little bit of
footage we got from her last movie it
looks like she was doing like a good job
like she was not really heard of I feel
like she was really giving it her all
when she was actually on set yeah I
think so too it's too bad the stress
it's stress you know that's where a lot
of it comes from and the fact she wanted
to totally change her image like that
take it seriously I mean I don't know
all of her personal life well you can
find out it's on Google but you can find
that Tyrone Power Tyrone you should have
called himself that Magnus you should
have gone Tyrone Power that sounds way
cooler that's my new name Power Greg
power no Tyrone Power Tyrone Power not
Lisa no Lisa power doesn't work
what are those is real last name google
it we should come boys I'm Google gonna
find out the truth
Tyrone power power easily a Wikipedia
page solve this Tyrone Wow
the powers are longer did they make it
sound like it was in the sword fight at
first but it wasn't it was no yeah it
happened like during the sword during it
wasn't like the sword gone no not in the
heart which would have been a cooler
story oh it's never cool to die never
cool the deities never cool to die
is a way more interesting sort do you
think the heart attacks stems from the
impact put into the spite and making it
real or is it wait what do you think
just sums up why that specific moment
yeah I'm sure it's a build up of a lot
of things a lot of times heart attacks
are linked to stress more than they are
linked to just bad eating you know
obesity can we can lead to things such
as heart attack or stroke but a lot of
time with stress to get back to that I
don't know what diet was really like
when especially back then these fight
scenes like we were talking about this
earlier Greg and I about fight scenes
and how it's more of like a
choreographed routine for your parents
later it's like a dance and I know sword
fights can't always be that but since
you have more of that in there I don't
know I feel like it's safer almost than
this then the scenes we get today with
all the blood and guts like I'm that's
why I'm wondering where does this
hardest heart attack sound from and it
sucks when an actor's last movie is also
yeah like a movie that's not considered
to be that great yeah you know there's
actors who didn't died during the film
but like when alia died her last minute
came out was Queen of the Damned
wasn't that great wasn't that great raúl
juliá was street fighter at this I
haven't seen it but hey I'm sure you had
Lazaro was you know legendary yeah
Scalia Sullivan the actor who played
pretty epic that's pretty cool it's it
that when I I wished I was in my
bloodline like my great grandfather
played Zorro that yeah you know I'm
actually related to Anthony Hopkins how
many plays or Oh in the masses or oh wow
give me the tree my mind doesn't work
that fast when I lie Oliver Reed he
drank what Lisa usually does every
Friday night guys wow I'm true I don't
understand his recipe this was a recipe
for failure he was literally drink
himself to death okay I mean my half a
bottle of whiskey gotta know your limits
okay be smart when you drink
that's what Oliver Reed taught us that's
what Oliver Reed taught us this is great
video for college kids perhaps
alcoholism is a great way to become a
great actor a lot of great actors have
become alcoholics not because they want
to further their acting you guys know
but because they get so invested into
the darkness of these characters and in
their personal life they search ranking
away their problems so Lisa know if
we're gonna be actors yes or no whoa
whoa Robert Downey jr. is career be
without him having drug abuse in his
past no it's part of what makes his
story awesome we got to be on the rise
and then we crash and then we have a
comeback when we're clean if that's one
beam because if we start off introduce
clean oh we haven't had any experience
in life but if we start off with
terrible experiences like Drew Barrymore
when she was young and chewing that
story yeah that's what I mean yes sir
party while our career and on the rise
and then we fall what happened we get
clean life eration
messy enough without the alcohol trust
me you learn so much understand okay
John Candy this guy was a hilarious dude
I watched a lot of his movies when I was
much I know I'm still overweight but
I've been working on my health a lot
more he looks great even though I want
to get McDonald's after this then we get
out my help a lot more lately isn't the
route it's not having alcohol you're not
gonna be an alcoholic you get fat that's
how you know we were joking that's when
you see getting fats another one and
then you lose a bunch of way people
watch you look great when you're on the
cover of all the magazines act because
they see the before and after fired our
Chris Pratt was fat all these movies now
he's both what's your workout routine uh
well you know it takes many shots yeah
it is yeah you cut back on the beer but
there get into this intricate oh I you
know I lift weights now workout three
times a week
[ __ ] why did we get so ate when I
see like huge comedians like really
overweight comedians I went to the
comedy store recently oh and there was a
comic there who was doing who's doing a
whole routine opposite wait I know like
really overweight comics they usually
have ups it yeah and it's like yes this
is funny you're doing what you want to
do I can't help but be a little concern
for you here do you know I definitely am
concerned because sometimes I realize
they're making a joke out of something
they know they need to work on
yeah which can be funny cuz a lot most
of us uh-oh
at least in the survivor and tend to
have some type of weight struggle at
some point and so we can really we can
relate to it it's a yes so the fat jokes
can't be funny however when you're like
45 and then you're still really huge I
started to get concerned that I want you
to stick around long another ways to be
funny without relying a big fat randomly
The Crow I don't think I've ever talked
about this movie on my channel I don't
think The Crow is a movie I grew up on
Brandon Lee is Bruce Lee's son and Bruce
Lee passed away and eventually when
Brandon Lee grew up he got into movies
and this was his last film The Crow was
such an impactful movie it was based on
a comic book of the crow this was before
every movie was a comic book and it was
real it's really [ __ ] good I don't
think a little kid should be watching it
but I did and it turned out fine okay
there were no struggles along the way it
is also the easiest smooth easy yeah my
life is peachy constantly never a stress
that is I've ever had to endure anyway I
actually met the guy who shot Brandon
Lee and this is not a joke
no he had a at the time when I met him
he was he was running a candle store or
something like that
Oh some type of store in Sherman Oaks I
felt really bad for the guy
cuz you know I
that definitely affected his career he
wasn't he wasn't able to excel as far as
he could have because of an accident
that wasn't his fault
it's just after that he was like no as
the guy who accidentally shot randomly
you know the funny thing about the crow
is that it's the number one if you
follow like any basic movie news right
now The Crow is a movie that has been in
development for its reboot for so long
has been shifting through so many
directors and now it's being passed in
another studio to think that if Brandon
Lee didn't pass away we probably could
have just had a really awesome franchise
with him instead of a bunch of bad
movies that followed after right and a
bunch of bad experiences it's cool that
he got to go out on a high note and that
it wasn't a yeah and he didn't get he
didn't end his career or image in a way
that was replica of his his father you
know like which isn't a bad thing Bruce
Lee is a legend but it's cool that he
was able to create a new image yeah yeah
his own self and I don't know one way to
go out
Dianna set Dianna set as actors we can
that's that's how I think I want to do a
crying deathbed scene where I confessed
that I killed everyone that my family
loved because I wanted to keep my family
to myself yeah yeah but I'm using my
real life experience is the Channel
District because that's what actors do
then I died on the scene and then I
diarrhea live oh my god is he
have you been thinking about this or did
you just think of that I thought about
this for many years I have a whole
script ready can I see it yeah 400 pages
I gotta trim it down a little bit I'm
still like at least 380 don't wanna be 0
right now drawn out to run out yeah nose
is there on the broader 20 more pages
yeah people would give up by that point
if you're new to the channels in general
there's a subscribe button it makes me
look better
subscribe please yeah Lisa milk
good the other Melman Murray it's cute
lisa-marie place the marine Lisa
mihalick is a wonderfully talented I'm
gonna do I'm gonna be genuine here I'm
an acting class with this girl and man
this lady kills it every single class
and I've learned so much from her from
just watching her she's gonna be someone
really famous I'm Gretta I'm glad that
she's here right now at this couch so
that way we can establish a friendship
on camera yeah that way if you like to
sign not to be friends of me down the
road when you're super famous you look
like a horrible
so not man can change you trust me I
know fans change me I have a celebrity
Oh God
I mean yeah who has more than four
hundred thousand subscribers not even
Tyrone Power